I do want to talk about this story
though ladies and gentlemen it's not
going to be Donald Trump
nor will it be Joe Biden the man who
will save this world is Elon Musk
I'm being facetious that's kind of the
joke but I'm I'm also only half joking
aside from Elon challenging The
Narrative machine of the ADL calling out
corrupt politicians securing not
perfectly but helping people bring back
free expression on social media Elon
Musk it has been reported now averted
World War III and may have saved the
planet from nuclear annihilation
the probability of that being the
circumstance is probably very very low
but it just sounds fun so I want to say
it the story is actually really simple
we have this from The Washington Post
Elon Musk cut internet to Ukraine's
military as it was attacking Russian
Fleet
so the first story that comes out is
that while this major counter-offensive
was underway Elon Musk shuts down
starlink cutting their Communications
stopping the offensive Elon Musk
responded saying there was an emergency
request from government authorities to
activate starlink all the way to
Sebastopol the obvious intent being to
sink most of the Russian Fleet at anchor
if I had agreed to their request then
SpaceX would be explicitly complicit in
a major Act of war and conflict
escalation
I wonder if uh wrong article if Ukraine
sank Russia's Black Sea Fleet using
SpaceX using U.S weapons and
intelligence would Russia have
dramatically escalated the conflict at
the time there is a possibility it may
have been the case I don't know for sure
but Elon Musk refused to provide
starlink to be used by the ukrainians in
this counter-offensive do you may have
single-handedly stopped a major
escalation which could have led to world
war three do you know what uh the size
of the fleet was in the makeup of the
fleet and sevastopol at the time no we
do know that
um U.S provided intelligence to Ukraine
to sink their flagship
yep Ukraine used U.S weapons and
intelligence
and I I think it's even unfair to say
the U.S sank the flagship of Russia's
Black Sea Fleet and and Ukraine was
intending to do more damage and Elon
Musk said I'm not going to assist you
with this
could you imagine if he did
that's crazy
he was pretty open in the early days
that he didn't want to be involved with
the war and I think he was gonna give
them he was going to send Starling to
Ukraine and then they they said no
because they wouldn't do it under his
terms or something and then he was like
okay then and they're like actually we
need it
so then he and then he sent it over
there it was a long time ago
yeah he's trying to protect Earth until
we can get off of it and go to Mars you
know The Men Who Built America were not
politicians they were businessmen yeah
but but I'm curious I mean
in terms of the unit party establishment
machine
man Elon Musk is running a foul but it
shows the the decay of the uniparti
power in that Elon Musk openly defies
them does not allow them to wage war
using his infrastructure this is
unprecedented if you look at Twitter
before Elon they gleefully gave the
government anything they wanted
it kind of I'm I'm I'm optimistic man
he's making me into a bigger fan so but
I'm just I'm a CIA I'm looking at a
restoration of true American values of
decentralization of power and for the
longest time we had an authoritarian
uniparty that did whatever it wanted
regardless of the Constitution now you
look at all of their devices you look at
the activist base you look at the
narrative machine and they're failing
across the board
people tweeting about how the ADL no
longer has any power they say oh all
these people who are criticized because
our white supremacists and everyone
laughs no one cares anymore they they're
they're they're they have been defanged
it's kind of like the uniparty when two
unit parties go at it it creates an
opportunity for a revolution that's what
happened with two unit parties yeah you
don't need a revolution revolution's a
bad word what happened with the American
founding fathers is that there was a
uniparty of of the Brits and there was
the uniparty of the oh that is
completely they went at each other and
the result was a Liberation they were
they were totally different countries
though yeah and they were like two
separate like they were monarchs they
were Monarch they were literal
uniparties and now we have the American
uniparty of the liberal economic order
and the Chinese ruse liberal like or not
liberal
and they're clashing in Ukraine so now
there's an opportunity for like
businessmen to step in and create
something new I I see what you what you
are saying like the author the
unilateral rule of the of the United
States clashing with other
authoritarians but Russia may be aligned
with China and bricks and everything but
when you get to the global scale it's
not una party there's greater conflict
between nations I suppose the ccp's unit
party and a party refers to in the
United States the Democrats and
Republicans that are secretly aligned
and pretend to be opposed yeah well the
Chinese Communist party is literally a
una party that runs that country but the
United States and China are not aligned
so it's not a global uni party it's no
no it's two unit parties going at each
other so that's why I think it's an
opportunity for for the private sector
to be like well you guys quibble we're
gonna create something functional
and you see Elon doing it in real time
maybe we should call in the United
States the former unit party because
they've lost too much power at this
point
you know look I know that they're
arresting and charging people and all
that stuff but they're really failing at
it every step of the way their their
their ability to influence is weakening
drastically uh midi Hassan uh interview
um Vivek ramaswamy and there's lag it's
MSNBC 2023 and they still have lag in
their video conference well it's always
been like yo brilliant it has like I use
zoom there's no lag I use Skype there's
no lag what the hell infrastructure is
this archaic dinosaur of a media
monolith using that they're still
freaking lag and they can't have
sometimes they can't even figure out
stereo and mono like you guys are in one
ear and like do you guys remember when
CNN did the satellite interview from the
same parking lot
yeah two people in the same parking lot
and they did a satellite interview as if
there were different places so the
reason I brought up lag in MSNBC is
because I think that's just evidence of
what you're saying that the uniparty
function is crumbling they're just so
behind the times oh the ratings are in
the gutter their influence is down is is
almost gone uh the fact that Elon bought
Twitter and turned it into X is a huge
example of this they were using Twitter
as a weapon to spy on people to control
and to influence and now they've lost it
it's remarkable how much they keep
losing which is why they're getting
desperate and trying to remove Trump
from the ballot and have him and have
him arrested because they know they're
losing I'd like for the American
government to win I don't know if
there's just one government I'd like for
the Americans I'd like people to win me
too yeah I'm on that team you know what
I will say that they're that we're
winning the American people are winning
when Assange is freed when we have
Edward Snowden back in the U.S without
fear of him going to jail for a long
time when people like Ross all break
their free like I I I I hear what you're
saying and I want to believe it but
we're not there quite yet we sent a man
to we just sentenced a man to 22 years
in prison to Enrique tario which I don't
agree with him you know necessarily but
what did he do he wasn't even in the
Capitol Building like what are we doing
here agreement is entirely irrelevant
I'm not trying to like the to even
discuss whether or not you agree
actually blunts the point it doesn't
matter it does not matter however
internet people will then be like oh my
God you're a fan I mean I I was already
called you know in during my campaign I
took a picture with somebody and they
were like terrible in their contempt
welcome they're contempt I I work for it
absolutely but I'm just saying I don't
support the proud boys however you know
what they've done to this guy is
horrible absolutely horrible and if they
can do it to him they can do it to you
and that's the problem if they're going
to come after people it's going to be
People Like Us in this room it's going
to be people who are speaking out and
saying things and if they can put
Enrique Taria who three I don't know
five years ago I don't even know who the
guy was and all of a sudden he's he
deserves 22 years in prison
he texted people to go do something if I
text you to go do something are you
gonna do it the defense said that he
wasn't in contact with anyone that day
and apparently the prosecution and the
media is reporting that he said don't
leave but we I don't know the context to
what she said don't leave was it the day
before they were like Hey we're in DC
which we know is like well don't leave
and now they're making it seem like he
was saying stay in the capital the
defense that he didn't contact them at
any point uh I will say
if it comes to the point where they
begin going beyond the scope of you know
oh and Shroyer who is on the ground and
they're saying his speech warrants a
prison sentence
he was on the ground and that's their
pretext for the arrest if they escalate
to the point where they're coming after
pundits I would argue that out of anyone
in this room Ian's the first person they
target
man you know why like a long hair bro
and I'm a wizard this happened with uh
uh when I was with Lou krutkowski in
Chicago and the police planted we
believe they planted drugs in the
apartment we're staying at
they target people who are less likely
to be able to muster up legal defense
funds so if they wanted to disrupt a
show like this and make claims about
rhetoric or inflammatory things uh would
they go after me well that's probably a
bad idea would create a huge PR press
storm it would create a huge backlash we
generate tons of money and it would
create a huge legal fight would they go
after Phil Labonte multi-platinum
recording artist I mean that could
create a huge wave across the
entertainment industry Ian on the other
hand you are you have the the you are
the least likely of anyone here to be
able to muster up a strong legal defense
granted we would defend you what I'm
saying is I don't think anyone's going
to come and try and arrest you I'm
saying the target of who they go after
is who can we get easily Enrique tario
the proud boys most people don't know
who he is they're not gonna look yeah
they they're they're waiting to go after
Trump until they can build everything up
on the ground because they know a direct
move against Trump is it makes it
millions of dollars it strengthens them
I've never been a trump supporter and
all of a sudden I'm like you know what
I'm going for the political prisoner
like that's it so who else right so
Vivek Rama Swami yes but I do like Vivek
also however is he gonna be the nominee
but you look at January 6 and they go
after people you've never heard of that
don't make the press and you don't even
know are in jail and these people try as
they might can't get the word out
there's too many of them this is what
they do one at a time
then they announce two and a half years
later that Owen Shroyer will be
criminally charged they're they're
they're starting from the bottom and
moving upwards it's very much like um
that story I talked we talk about eBay
you know when eBay was started it was
yellow and they wanted to change the
background to white but everyone got mad
so they did it one step at a time over
the course of a year they don't want to
come out immediately right after January
6 and say Donald Trump you're under
arrest it would create chaos they got to
go for the easier low-hanging fruit
which is
lower income people who are confused and
then what do they do they go to this you
know 37 year old woman who was walking
around the capitol waving a flag when
everyone in the building and they say
you're gonna go to prison for eight
years for for a felony charge for
terrorism
or you're going to write a letter saying
Trump made you do it
and then we're gonna say you can go home
right now time served and they they've
all how many people have taken this deal
how is it that any different to our
regular justice system well no but this
is my point my point is
they if they go head-to-head with Trump
trump rallies his base sure if they
weaken his Base by getting his
supporters to write letters saying Trump
did this and ordered me to do it and
then used it for propaganda knowing
these people no one will ever hear their
names
they won't raise money it's also laid
that base now that you've heard that all
these people have been charged if you're
a layperson you know you go to work
every day you got the kids you got stuff
going on you're not really paying
attention you have no idea what these
people have been charged with you here I
don't know how many people have been
arrested now all of a sudden it's like
an actual thing it's like well all those
people are arrested of course they had
to have done something terrible so it
adds to that level of yeah they did
something of course you got to go for
Trump because he's the orchestrator of
all these people they get enough people
to sign letters saying Trump ordered me
to do it then they say we have sworn
witness testimony from 372 people saying
Trump instructed them to do it under
duress of course but is that not
mattered in the argument that it's it's
it's part of the strategy so ultimately
my point is if they start going after
personalities oh and Shroyer I think
proves this point one they have a
pretext he was on the capitol grounds
shouldn't have done it you go to prison
for three months that's ridiculous but
they're using his speech the speech is
opening the door to targeting other
personalities who are online the next
person will likely see charge is going
to be someone who maybe has a hundred
two hundred thousand followers of
subscribers and they're gonna say they
advocated for incited and instructed
people to commit a crime
I'm gonna tell you right now there were
people on Twitter on YouTube and other
social platforms before January 6 who
posted videos advocating for people to
engage in direct conflict
and really like violent conflict
and there's no question about it
I think these people some of whom have
instantly flipped and become total
disanta supporters
probably flipped because they know uh-oh
they're they're next in line
after the j6s were on the ground they're
going to come out and say you committed
an act of sedition by making these
videos advocating for Insurrection
against the United States government
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time